prima di partire volevo ringraziarvi
veramente di cuore non pensavo che in
così tanti avrebbero utilizzato il
codice creatore mio io l'ho messo
durante il video detto vabbè chissà
qualcuno lo usa
avete usato in tantissimi cioè in un
solo episodio fatto non so migliaia di
codici di di support dico riciclatore
grazie a tutti di cuore se volete
supportarmi con il codice creatore fa vj
è questo qui aspetta che questo qua che
tiro su sempre con la magia se arriviamo
a 100 mila supporter faccio il video di
four nights è nudo vi lascio al video
ragazzi
buona visione potete davvero prima di
iniziare se perché mi piacciono nessun
sacra come ai maiali da ho fatto così a
te non ti sei fatta niente ho colpito
lui era ucciso come possibile spiegami
cosa ho appena visto a questi se ne va e
quelli che arrivano quindi sono dei
crediti arrivano in faccia e te li
prendi in testa quindi è un livello con
un marco che dovremmo mal di testa da
porto dello chi l'ha sopra questo come
si fa aiuto jolo così attori di rischi
marea si edili pure continueranno ad
ronzio vabbè sera scivoli sono tornato
ma siccome mi ha seccato utenti sono
tornato qui ottenuti tranquillo per i
veicoli
ok va avanti ed eviti può saltare più o
meno a metà ghiaccio in modo tale da
arrivare a quello successivo poi ti
fermi brufoli di andare e quando i
capitoli ma la mente è l'obiettivo è
arrivare alla fine della mappa altro
nella cima arrivi lì hai finito
sì va bene io penso di riuscire a farlo
in un tentativo solo vedere
si ok 1 prova 23 estero credi che arriva
quattro attenzione guarda 5 aiuto ha
detto a ciocchetti cavolo ero preso bene
è fighissimo mi diverto un sacco rai e
bellissimo è veramente geniale che
inventato st robben gelli e bellissime
veramente devi sapere che questa è la
prima fase la seconda è un po peggio
pure c'è un'altra fa è perché non
bastava sta roba vedi deve poi ci sono
quelle cose quelle costruzioni nere qui
muretti no va bene non parole siete gesù
e li peggiora molto pure ahia ahia che
male al naso è salito ne è davvero e
perché poi qui è difficile trovare il
punto hayek è male ma donna oramai
sembra che ci mirino prova arrivano
esattamente dove derivati è
impressionante ed è veramente bello vi
piace ce n'è uno che è rimasto fermo a
ma puoi usarli iniziamo la tecnica un po
segreta a devi riuscire a chi sa parli
al volo preso dovranno comunque con
tanto di difficilissimo anche quei
veicoli direi così travolto milan è
terzo e partire tipo missy è difficile
anche così però sto facendo senza da
qualcosa faccio allora praticamente da
lì diventare e in diagonale secoli fino
alla destra esatto e poi devi salire
sopra il muretto mi odi ora non vedo si
arriva roba è una roba vi prego poi
andare prendere prendere prendere
prendere vado ok adesso ti vendere
stupro il muretto ce l'ho fatta raga ce
l'ho fatta ok bravissimo grazie no
aspetta
e successo così crimine investito mai
salvato e stato bellissimo ma vabbè jolo
jolo mio zio visibile è stato fortissimo
adesso lo stesso concetto però bisogna
andare in diagonale e salire di nuovo
sul no sto sudando impossibile e mi
manca ancora no no così non si può ma
come fai a aspetta che arriva un
arrivano adesso ne vanno dritto
adesso vai mio dio perfetto e adesso di
contrada destra mamma mia
no mi apre non mi ha buttato che
esistano cosa non fare i bagagli la
porta alla destra
sì a dio vedere lì
ce l'ho fatta già fatta ce l'ha fatta ma
che quella è una sorta di check point è
più o meno perché poi si sa bene cosa
adesso va bene haga è stato orribile ho
pochissima vita tra sempre in un altro
che ti sono morto però sono quasi in
dirittura d'arrivo ci provo no no dai vi
prego no no no no voglio morire la cai
ragano è possibile ma i blues si se non
puoi farlo c'è assurdo ripeto non so se
qualcuno l'ha mai finito a piedi e
massino è assurdo c'è rimasto un
chiedilo a ferno da solo si è quello che
ho perché già attivato il problema da
prenderlo
mio dio e si può finire qui caddy ti
però è in un modo un po strano non ti
aspettare nulla di crafting di sensi o
che adesso a parte la prima parte ok con
un po di consegna si arriva così ci si
fa impennare e poi si usa il turno o mio
dio sa però che click da pape è quanto
mai fatto delle cose che non saprei
spiegare in fisica però va bene raga
ragazzi ho trovato a fermarti valenti è
rimasto un ragazzo si sa sta sono fatta
e come occhio aiuta occhio leviamoci dio
mio dio devo solo tagliando sanno dritto
dritto la faccio e farò ce la farò lo
sento mi sento tantissimo mi sento
tantissimo rocket l'ing
e vabbè ma ce l'ho fatta
non ce l'ha fatta ci ha fatto ridere se
non deve cadere e devi riuscire a farlo
una seconda volta no perché hai citato
di là perché aspettano non è vero non è
vero
credici bravo esatto beni bravissimo no
che so che sfiga si era
impossibile occhio se riesci apre sai
cosa se riesci a prendere la rampa un
velo di lato riesci impennarsi forse
riesce a prendere il caso più avanti ma
questa è l'unico livello fatto così ci
sono anche altri ecco in culo e le ha
copiato prediletto non un livello intero
così grande però ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho
fatta ce l'ho fatta il cavo sa cosa già
fatta il primo mio primo prima esiti mai
ce l'ho fatta che secondarie
ci sono mai vincente point o e c'è un
lama allora via motore aero freno ok
capisco buono non è proprio un ottimo
giro voi
ok ragazzi non hanno sparare ai ragazzi
parare due ragazzi o 28 limite correte
arrivo correte dai ha bloccato
te l'ho fatto io ci sono io ci sono ma
allora deve aspettare che o mio dio mio
dio ma perché tutto adesso si ok non ho
trovato tre di vita la gara difficile
dobbiamo scendere di gigi ce l'ha fatta
3 di vita orribile ragazzo è stato
bellissimo non paga è stato veramente
figo
sono soddisfattissimo pure bello che nel
finale si ride
abbiamo finito la valascia sono riuscito
io non so come è finita pure non so con
quale bo stregoneria successo non lo so
sono esplosi anche io esploso pavimento
mi fa ripartire da lì ma chi se ne frega
infatti ormai praga super super contento
e niente questo era il gas i two player
non consapevole partecipato questo video
iscrivetevi al the players che la shin
descrizione e io come sempre più
ringrazi bravi subito
mi piace iscrivetevi al canal e ciné ma
non possiamo da ragazzi
[Musica]